- [Nurse] Here we go.
- I definitely think
that it's gonna become
one of those things that
just happens at universities
of submitting your vaccination record.
- I know of a lot of people
who've stayed home for
first and second semester,
but I think a lot of them
are planning to come
to campus in the fall.
- [Narrator] A growing number
of colleges around the country
will require students get vaccinated
before returning to campus in the fall.
- That means a lot more in-person events,
in person activities and classes.
Of course masks and social distancing
may still be a part of campus life,
but certainly more
classes will be happening
inside the class than they have this year.
- [Narrator] But the mandates
are stirring up controversy
about the legality, and whether colleges
can make vaccinations a
condition of attendance.
Will the requirements help campus
return to some semblance
of normal in the fall?
Or will there be legal setbacks?
(light upbeat music)
For Northeastern, a private
university in Boston,
the school says herd
immunity is the best path
to return its 18,000 undergraduates
to fully in-person classes.
- The magic of an undergraduate degree
is that you're close to your friends
and you're close to your
classmates and you learn together.
But that same thing that makes
it so rich and interesting
does allow the virus to spread.
- [Narrator] Northeastern
Administrator, Michael Armini,
believes the school is
on solid legal ground
with the requirements.
- So we're gonna require
the COVID-19 vaccine
for the same reason
that we have always required
vaccinations of students,
whether it's for measles
or mumps or meningitis,
and it's to keep the community safe.
- [Narrator] Northeastern
reopened last fall,
but with frequent COVID testing,
social distancing protocols,
and limited in-person classes.
- You never know if
someone has coronavirus.
So it's just that whole issue
of I want to meet new people.
I want to get into my
new college environment.
But is it safe to do so yet?
I'd say that was the biggest stressor
of going to college this year,
which was definitely unique for our class.
- [Narrator] Cole
Clericuzio is a freshmen,
and says his experience has
been anything but normal.
He works part time as an EMT,
treating COVID patients up close.
So he jumped at the
opportunity to get vaccinated.
- Definitely when I saw
that I had an opportunity
to get an appointment, and
I took the first available.
There was no question in my mind.
- [Narrator] He's even been volunteering
to help get people vaccinated,
and appeared in the school produced PSA.
- If I could carry vaccines with me,
I'd just walk around
giving them to people.
It's that easy.
- [Narrator] Like many
of the other schools
mandating the vaccine,
Northeastern says it will allow
for medical and religious exemptions.
But Armini says that making
this announcement early
will allow vaccine hesitant
students to make other plans
because they won't be allowed on campus.
- I mean, we hope it doesn't come to that.
We hope that over the summer
anyone who may have
some vaccine hesitancy,
that that sort of dissipates over time.
One thing that we always
find with students
is that peer to peer is very powerful.
So if their friends are being vaccinated
and they're enthusiastic
about it, that helps a lot.
- [Narrator] Other colleges are hoping
they can reach herd
immunity without a mandate.
Texas A&M and Virginia Tech
believe the requirements
conflict with federal law
because the FDA has only allowed
the emergency use of the vaccines.
- I think a lot of it's just becoming
very politically charged,
this debate around vaccine passports.
By getting a vaccine you're
allowed to do certain things,
and by not getting it you're
left out of those things.
So places like Florida, Arizona, Texas,
Utah specifically says that
public higher ed institutions
are not allowed to require
vaccination of students,
faculty and staff in
order to be on campus.
- [Narrator] The country's
largest university systems,
the University of California
and California State University,
recently announced they
intend to require vaccinations
for the more than a million
students and faculty,
but say the timing of
a more formal mandate
will depend on when the FDA
gives full authorization
to one or more of the vaccines.
It could come before
or after classes start.
Many schools aren't wasting any time.
They've launched vaccination blitzes
and public health campaigns
to get students immunized before
they leave for the summer.
- Protecting the path, we're
all getting tested regularly,
making sure to fill out
our daily wellness checks.
- [Narrator] Last week Cornell University
in Ithaca, New York held
a pop-up vaccination event
on campus that provided
Moderna shots to students.
The school says that nearly 50%
of the current on-campus
population is already vaccinated.
Senior Jade Ovadia says she's relieved
to see more and more of
her classmates vaccinated.
- So I'm fully vaccinated,
as are many of the Cornell students.
Everybody is very eager to get vaccinated.
You know college life,
you only get to have it
really once in your life.
And COVID-19 kinda
interrupted that for us.
And these are years that
we don't really get back.
So I think we're all just
really eager and willing
to take whatever actions that will help us
be able to return back to that experience.
(light upbeat music)